good morning Millennials
welcome to Illyria welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome to a morning
rose hello everyone happy Tuesday
welcome back to the morning to us we
hope you had a splendid evening really
just splendid yeah how could it be
though with two hours of The Bachelor so
actually despite the two hours of The
Bachelor I did have a splendid evening
because I started a new book and it's
fabulous
I had a splendid evening as well except
I don't know if anyone follows my
husband on Instagram but for the second
time in a row Ben has broke our bed he
just jumps around on it so much and you
know he's not a small person he's just
like throwing his weight around and of
course our wooden bed slats have now
been severed in half and I ordered a new
metal one but it hasn't come yet so we
are now going on two nights of sleeping
in a broken bed and my back is aching my
belts too tight my hips are shaken from
left to right and it wasn't that great
of a night for me I'm not gonna lie that
makes sense as 2ic of sleeping through
class this morning he's he's really been
taking the brunt of it cuz usually Ben
will sacrifice his own comfort to let
the ill like sleep in his legs or sleep
in his armpit but we are so
uncomfortable in this bed for the past
few nights like Thea was not a concern
it's like [ __ ] you gotta fend for
yourself you're a real dog now put your
crate yeah no or like sleep on the floor
oh my god are you kidding never I know
but let's be more comfortable in a
sunken in bed um no why don't you put
your mattress on the floor
um how big do you think my room is like
I've space for a bed and then also get
rid of the bed no because the bed is
fine it's just like the internal slat so
we ordered a new slat so my bed frame is
gonna be fine oh okay so it's just like
a missing part maybe I should go to a
hotel Oh crazy so crazy to be honest Ben
side is really broken so like mine is
livable and he is just literally
sleeping on the floor good that's what
he liked for being so happy with my
furniture not affecting you why don't
you guys get a Sleep Number bed so you
guys can set it to your preference
preferences like a good idea in theory
if you guys like different kinds of beds
and I don't know maybe you just say
Sleep Number enough times in the morning
toast one will appear at your door
that's true find out what number you
like I was trying to get Ben to sleep on
the couch like not to be like rude you
know trouble in paradise but like we
have a great couch no one ever sits on
it like us about it oh for sure no Zach
love you but sleep on it we have the
same couch Zack always falls asleep on
the couch immediately every single night
and then he comes into the bed no one
has ever slept on my couch except one of
Ben's friends one time like crashed on
our couch but I've never ever slept on
my couch I've never even napped on my
couch I'm a dead person through and
through no Ben she talked to Zach did
you see that I said about sleeping on
the couch yes I was like that Zach
except that he's like self-imposed he's
not in trouble
I've never insisted that he sleep on the
couch but I do not stop him because I
love having the bed to myself no I fully
insisted bed sleep on the couch I wasn't
even trying to be subtle and he just did
not take it well he was like like same
on the [ __ ] couch you broke the bed
two beds in a row like you don't learn a
lesson now Oh living with a child that's
what having a husband is except a child
doesn't break the bed they just peed the
bed break stuff and like you're always
cleaning up after them like I'm always
just like every morning then takes a
shower underwear on the sink there's a
laundry basket
right there like it's so endearing I
think that's hitting in these Carano
time you can't do [ __ ] like that we have
such an exciting stories for you today
lots of Corona updates learning news we
have a major announcement that we
launched on our Instagram yesterday I
don't know if you're following at toast
news network it's like the most premium
Instagram account if you're looking for
you know insight into everything going
on here at toast HQ but we have launched
our new show it's called Maternity Live
hosted by our sister Olivia ashtray she
is pregnant she is going through life
she is a businesswoman people like
always want advice from her I think her
DMS are flooded with people who just
have like random life advice for
questions yeah and she's really like
this hub of wisdom when it comes to
business and now when it comes to
motherhood she's always been like this
maternal figure in our lives so she
would decided to launch a podcast you
could subscribe on Spotify on iTunes
it's available anywhere you can find
podcasts all the places you listen to
the morning toast the first episode is
dropping Thursday and then they will be
dropping every Thursday after that on
this particular episode all Steen's are
on deck so olivia has a little part in
the beginning the episode in the meal
all join in about 20-25 minutes in there
is so much happening on the stream right
now there's an ambulance there is a
vacuum let's take a break and I'm gonna
frame myself better
so make sure you check all that out we
have you know so much going on here at
US News Network that if you're not
following Aptos news network
I feel as though you'd be missing out on
major pertinent information I totally
agree I see that toast news network is
getting a lot of followers I know she's
almost had 18,000 which I'm not gonna
lie for a passion project is kind of
crazy I know that's how I feel about the
redheads we're at like 17,000 I'm not
like 17,000 people following and an
Instagram account about books mm-hmm I'm
very pleased
yeah it's honestly probably a really
hard Instagram account to create content
for and that's why I just let you you
know run with it and you're doing a
really good job thank you I think like
the the brand message is really on point
you know everyone understands where
we're headed where we're going yeah and
it's just been a great time for the
redhead so I just want to say like if I
haven't said it yet make sure to check
out the redheads two episodes are up
it's just fun hanging out with your
friends even if you're not interested in
the books but I am so excited about
maternity live it's the podcast that
everybody asked everyone's been asking
for and we worked so hard on the name we
had so many different options but I
think we landed on a good one I think
everyone's really gonna love it it's so
punny maternity live and she's going on
maternity live um I know it's not a
story but it was in page six this
morning and I just don't know if like
everyone has heard about it yet but I
ate an apple this morning I heard about
it because I was looking in page six for
stories for today and it did come up
it's like a really big deal yeah girl
with no job ate an apple do I look
different I you look a little bit like
Gwyneth Paltrow really yeah that was
definitely like the Apple I ate I could
just feel when it's this vibe like
pulsing through the fibers so how did it
feel to eat the apple it was just like
this crazy thing because I think that
every time we wrap the show I'm starving
and I just go have snacks because we
have a bunch of snacks at the office but
I felt like that's not a healthy way to
live and I've been finding so many
popcorn kernels in my teeth it's so
painful to be a popcorn here and I was
like what do people eat in the morning
and I really have a problem with
breakfast I don't eggs and I'm like
alright this Apple is in my fridge like
let me just try it out and like slice it
up and put in a little ziplock bag like
I was in middle school and it just felt
sliced Apple you didn't that wasn't
mentioned in page six oh and it's on my
Instagram story I don't know if you
follow me at girl with no job it's like
this kind of like big deal instagramming
I thought you had like the whole Apple
no I don't know you were going for a
slice you vibe that's so cute a slice
vibe is took by the apples and slice
form are so much better like having to
like put your big
like round hand on this like dirty apple
and then like the juice drips down your
wrist I hate like open your mouth so
wide you're like I'm gonna get lockjaw
totally so I was like slicing it up this
morning like Chef Boyardee in my kitchen
just like slice slice slice and I think
that it's gonna become like my new thing
wait love that for you
yeah I'm looking very much like a Fuji
apple kind of girl but I could do a
McIntosh every now and then I'm I prefer
a red apple but I don't really eat
apples because you know guys know I hate
fruit Jaggi is a self-imposed allergy to
no and also when I eat apples I do my
throat gets itchy mostly because the
pesticides these toxic chemicals that
our fruits are being cooked in those
damn pesticides but it's actually true
so even when I have my carrots any I
guess I'm just like allergic to fruits
and vegetables meat you know for sure
for sure I'm also allergic to like water
we're also gonna be recapping The
Bachelor at the end of the show so if
that's what you came here for stay tuned
lots of thoughts on barb Maddie the
whole drama we will get to it well but I
do think it's time because we actually
you do need to know these paths I
stories that you do need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and in these trying times
like you don't have time to just sit
around and wait for the fast 5 you don't
have time for pretty much anything
that's why fibre is such a pertinent
sponsor of today's show definitely when
it comes to finding freelance talent for
your business or project it can be
time-consuming frustrating and expensive
where do you go to find the talent how
much will it cost how can you be certain
that they'll deliver
thanks to fiber finding the right
freelancer it doesn't have to be a
struggle their marketplace helps you get
done more done with less fiber connects
businesses with freelancers who offer
hundreds of digital services including
graphic design and copywriting web Pro
rec programming film editing and more as
a burgeoning digital business who's
always looking for graphic designers
video editors Fiverr has been a perfect
marketplace for us I think a lot of you
guys can really benefit from it services
you can find where you're looking for
instantly you can search by service
deadline price reviews and more you'll
know exactly what you're paying for
upfront no negotiation needed it's also
interesting because when you're looking
for freelance you're not really you
don't really know how much like things
cost yeah so you don't to like offer
someone like so much money just a little
money when it's like a market place like
this it's like here's a price everything
is standard it makes it so easy this is
what it costs you it's really quality
talent that you can count on their
sellers have worked with some of the
most influential brands in the world
like the morning toast
Talon for your project has never been
easier you can review seller ratings by
your feedback and select the right
freelancer based on your budget take
five and check out fiverr.com and you
over seem to receive ten percent off
your order by using code toast it's so
easy don't waste any more time and get
the service you deserve by going to FIV
eerr dot-com Code toast Fiverr
it starts here Sion get amazing designs
for your small business or big business
okay first story it's the big story of
the day Coachella Music Festival likely
to be postponed to October amid
coronavirus outbreak jelly the annual
Coachella Valley Music and Arts Festival
is likely to be postponed amid concerns
over the novel coronavirus a source
confirms two people that golden voices
and talks to postpone the popular to
weekend festival to October and may make
an announcement imminently the festival
which take place in which takes place in
Indio California was originally
scheduled to take place on the weekends
of April 12th 10th through the 12th and
17th through the 19th it could now take
place the weekends of October 9th and
16th billboard reported Monday
stagecoach the country music festival
that also takes place in Indio is also
expected to be moved to October
according to Billboard yeah this is so
crazy I think this is like we've been
saying all along like what about
Coachella ladder by Coachella and when
this decision finally is going to come
down I think that'll really set the tone
for like where we're at in terms of
coronavirus panic yeah but the fact that
it's like maybe postponed that's so like
they you know - yeah cuz now we we can't
set the tone and also I had read a
comment earlier that um I am causing a
lot of hysteria hysteria about current
iris and I just want to say I
respectfully disagree but I also think
like we are the two types of coronavirus
patrons oh yeah I am like husband get
canned goods like we are gonna stay in
the house for 12 days and I'm like I
don't even have toilet paper so
hopefully we're gonna be fine yeah Zac
actually weirdly just you know how he is
a hoarder so we have like so much to a
paper and tissues in our house just
because that's who he is and he just did
a round of toilet paper not even knowing
Korona that there's a shortage so if any
if you need toilet paper we have so much
it wasn't it wasn't a panic by I just
want to let you guys know that I mean my
local Duane Reade is just the shelves
are ransacked rinse act is it really ya
know Lysol no Clorox no toilet paper
very few snacks
no canned goods crazy crazy I've been
seeing it all over Kyle Richards
Instagram story like the local
supermarket was completely empty all the
shells back to this couch Ellie thing I
just think that um
in October hotel a moment like could be
fabulous I'm so here for you and a Palm
Desert weather in an October weekend I
feel as though it's similar to April
probably if it's like fall but fall is
just more palatable than an early spring
and very few things happen in the fall
it's like it's really like a dry time of
year so I think that this could be like
a fabulous shift I agree especially for
stagecoach I don't know if I would go to
Coachella in the fall because I cherish
my Falls and like fall in New York they
didn't sorry October in New York is so
beautiful so I don't know that I need to
be like flying across the country you
know now that Coachella is just so like
up in the air I most likely will not be
going but I'm definitely gonna still go
to stagecoach because you can't you
can't stop me you can't stop the beat no
in October stagecoach moment sounds
fabulous yeah I think to me this is like
hopeful news like okay we're taking it
seriously but you know we will be fine
by the end of the year Jim yeah like
this is like a metaphor for where we're
at in terms of coronavirus so I'm
feeling okay you feeling decent oh so I
ride some safety tips this morning that
coronavirus I just want to share with
the class that we should not be shaking
hands or like hugging one another when
greeting and you can a wave is
appropriate or and this is what a doctor
said a peace sign how are you to be okay
so if you guys see me it's this that's
what I did you see me Chuck and doing my
whole life is just like being germ free
Chuck induces I just think it's so
important for people to know that a
peace sign can suffice in these Carano
times you know what else is important
for people to know or at least discusses
the genesis of the word deus because you
can chuck a do so you can take a deuce
you could play juicy trapa deuce yeah
you could take deuces and tennis like
what an interesting word what does it
mean to you know what
there's DOS there's an eye open make a
number to like a duty juice but just as
P sinus two fingers and then deuces in
Genesis like that two points ace deuce
okay so it means the two on dice or
playing cards so I guess it means two
and that way when you're Chucky
you're throwing up twos when you're
dropping a deuce you're taking the
number two it's also the two the tie
score about 40 all right with tennis
it's a win by two
yeah ace deuce you know you gotta buy
two
yeah and a $2 bill but that's an
informal dated definition because
there's no more $2 you know what other
word the genesis really shakes me ghetto
because when you think of the original
ghetto it's like the Holocaust yeah but
we don't consider ghetto to be like
where people were dying now you know no
crazy right very crazy words man they'll
do that to you
I know it's like especially when you
read and that's the nice thing about a
Kindle if you don't understand a word
you can click it and it gives you a
definition Wow yeah and then sometimes
they use such fabulous words that are
highlighted I'm like I wouldn't remember
that word yes you know what's a fabulous
word that you would like really want to
incorporate into your everyday life um
sporadically I hope not Bradley of
course okay well anyways we'll keep you
guys posted about Coachella um I'm sure
that decision will come will come soon I
wonder where they just don't make the
decision I guess they're holding out
hope to me like I just find this so
funny like for all the bloggers who like
are already packed you know we're gonna
unpack those bad no Valley and all the
how fits that I'm ready to purchase no
it's tiny like well those fashions hold
up in October right and to me like the
most fabulous part about this whole like
movement is the displacement of the
bloggers you know yeah it's funny but
then it's also like when in these
working from home times I think the
bloggers stand to do pretty well yeah I
think a lot of industries are being
impacted by this on this disease
whatever we're calling it but I think
bloggers and you know the stay-at-home
influencers are actually the one
untouchable industry because you could
really do that from anywhere that's true
and people are spending more times on
their phone because they're not at work
they're working from home I think we're
onto something and you know what I was
thinking yesterday like let's say like
everyone's office gets shut down like we
would still do the truss and we would be
like the only source of entertainment I
was thinking the same thing to that if
everyone had to stay home like we could
still do the toast even if we either met
up or we could do it on the integrated
interface and like we would be the news
yeah because if the news people can't go
can't show up cuz like news corpus
closed down like right hello Time Warner
hello hello Peyton that's a great thing
about being an
independent artists okay next story
playboy is going to end Playmate of the
Year in favor of inclusivity oh my god
you know what playboy has been a little
too all over the map for me you know
they became like a social magazine and
they stopped doing nudity and then they
went back to the nudity like just stick
with what works we have enough fake
magazines out there okay Wonderwall
magazine ID like there's all these fake
magazine so all the celebrity treat
always on the cover yeah bone Appetit
okay that's realizing but like we don't
need another okay we don't need another
like fake digital magazine let's just
put the titties like that's what people
want oh for sure but this is a this is
something else because it's the end of
the road for Playmate of the Year page
six is told since 1960 playboy has
handed out the award to its favorite
Playmate of the month from the previous
year given the honor to such skin
Superstars as Jenny McCarthy Anna Nicole
Smith and Victoria Sylvester over the
years but a rep for the magazine tells
page six that from now on it will be
replaced by playmates of the Year
celebrating all 12 diverse playmates of
the month from the previous year the rep
told us it's now a more inclusive
celebration okay so this is just like an
everyone wins situation like a very
teachery moment yeah they were already
all like they were playmates of their
individual month and now they're little
choosing one winner of the year I just
feel like a lot of brands are being left
behind for not evolving in these more
progressive times like Victoria's Secret
is a perfect example of a brand that
never evolved and is now really really
getting left behind and to me they
Playboy's the opposite like please stop
evolving like you were like this weird
incubator of like I don't know even know
what to call it but like it worked now
they just keep moving into the 21st
century like everyone wins and you know
we're not gonna put titties on the cover
anymore and you know what I never bought
a playboy but like I'm fine with it you
know I don't need a progressive porn
magazine yeah I would agree with that
also I do feel like playboy has been
left behind a little bit because when
you think of like sexy bikini shots and
like that's really Instagram course
Illustrated like they they didn't do a
good job of like a training the social
media age no I'd say every Instagram
model should be like if Playboy's not
doing all new it's like they should be
in Playboy yeah but it always is gonna
have that like porn connotation and most
Instagram models I don't want to be porn
stars they're just like when I get
really close
so I just think like they shot
themselves in the foot like they're
never gonna be this digital platform
that they want to be I'm sorry they ate
so I don't need this like you know this
woke playboy I'm good and if anything I
I think that taking out Playmate of the
Year when such iconic women have come
out of that title I think that's one of
the things that they're best known for
and this is not inclusive just making
everyone a winner like there's a there's
always like a Rookie of the Year Sports
Illustrated Maxim Hot 100 like lists are
very much like a 2020 thing the
sequencing are really everywhere was
already like their Playmate of the Month
so no one's getting anything new it's
just like someone's losing that title
yeah Timmy this is like the most random
thing they could have done this is not
real this change the thing that nobody
asked for yeah there's nothing wrong
with picking a winner
yeah there's beauty pageants like this
this is not real focus in my mo um the
last Playmate of the year that I can
remember is that girl that was on the
hills that birdy Jenner was dating Jade
do you remember her no did the black
hair the last Playmate of the Year I can
remember is Anna Faris oh of course
in the house but would we have gotten
the House Bunny if this decision had
come down sooner that's what I'm saying
now we have to think of all the amazing
movies we're gonna miss going forward
and what's penthouse up to what's that
like the other porn magazine I don't
know it seems like there's a gap in the
penthouse of the year market yeah
there's still definitely a marketplace
for print porn obviously since you know
the porn hubs I don't think that it's
you know a thriving business but there's
a place for it you know barber shops all
around the world are looking to
subscribe so playboy should just stick
to it I thought you said bar breath
shops all around the world no drama no
barber shops barber shops sorry
okay next up Angelina Jolie reveals two
of her daughters recently had surgery so
Angelina Jolie has written an essay for
Time magazine she is now a contributor
and she said that her two of her kids
recently underwent surgery quote I've
spent the last two months in and out of
surgeries with my eldest daughter and
days ago watched her younger sister go
under the knife for a hip surgery they
know that I am writing this because I
respect their privacy and we discussed
it together and they encouraged me to
write they understand that going through
medical challenges and fighting to
survive and heal is something to be
proud of that's crazy
that is really crazy teenager gets a hip
problem that's crazy I don't know
someone's gotten really sad there any
details about the other surgery um yeah
there's a lot of details it's it's a
long it's a long essay but she talks
about how the family was supportive and
sweet and how the medical professionals
they you know really checked in
co-parenting at its finest
well I'm wishing on the best uh actually
this has nothing to do with this I had a
very vivid dream last night that I met
Megan Markel like in a social setting
and she was so lovely and obviously I
took back everything that I said about
her and then she asked to join the
morning toasters Facebook group and she
had like known about it and so like I
don't think she could have approved her
question everything about her our
realistic dream so creepy Oh
vivid yeah it was really crazy but it
got me thinking yeah yes sometimes like
realistic dreams like you're when you
wake up and you're so happy that they
weren't real like I sometimes to this
day like have a really really bit of a
dream said I'm like about to go to class
and I didn't hand in my homework
um and then I've had like a really
really really realistic feeling dreams
for Zac Efron is my husband and I wake
up and I'm absolutely devastated to be
lying next to battery yeah so it's funny
how light dreams can like play tricks on
your mind you know it is funny but
there's nothing better than waking up
from a like waking up from a good dream
to your actual life is annoying but
there's nothing better than waking up
from a bad dream where like you know
someone you love died or like you ate
yep so my shiver of Dreams where you ate
so much and then like you wake up and
you're like oh my god oh wait I didn't
eat that oh you're sick sometimes I'm in
a dream and I'm eating so much but then
I realize it's a dream and I keep eating
cuz I'm like I don't have to stop myself
I'm gonna wake up and I don't have the
calories like sometimes I'm having an
amazing dream and I'll wake up for a
second be like it's a dream go back like
go date Zac Efron and that really is the
best type of dream because you can
really just play with your imagination I
have so many dreams where it's like I
know this is a dream and then I in the
dream I'm like I'm gonna prove to you
that this is a dream and I start like
there's books on the walls and I start
opening the books I'm like look but all
the text is there and I can't prove that
it's a dream that I know it's lit and
then I'm like wait maybe it's not a
dream
I have dreams where I'm like okay I know
this is a dream let me just fulfill all
my fantasies and like I'll literally
start flying and I I'm in my sleep I
think I literally clenched my shoulders
and my pheasant like fly [ __ ] and I'll
start flying that's my dream is to fly I
would love to just like soar past
traffic and like everyone's [ __ ]
Oh looking angelic with my pillow-talk
lipstick on my lips Oh is there anything
like that no we're gonna take a brief
moment to let you know about Charlotte
Tilbury a sponsor of today's episode the
woman behind the brand Charlotte Tilbury
is one of the most highly regarded and
influential
celebrity makeup artists of all time a
groundbreaking female entrepreneur and
founder of the eponymous company
Charlotte Tilbury beauty with 27 years
in the beauty industry Charlotte has
been responsible for the creation of
countless iconic beauty styles and is
regarded as a visionary and a
trendsetter in 2013 she forever changed
the face of global beauty with the
launch of her makeup and skincare
collection decoding her traditionally
closed or VIP expertise giving women and
men the tools to be the most beautiful
version of themselves her client list is
extensive making iconic beauty styles
from Kate Moss Amal Clooney Penelope
Cruz Keira Knightley Susan Sarandon
Gisele Bundchen never heard of her
Charlotte Tilbury Beauty has won over
280 awards globally and worked on over
180 magazine covers over 600 editorial
advertising campaigns so you know that
the woman behind the brand is super
legit and her pillow talk collection is
taking the world by storm I have it in a
few shades um but it's their
best-selling globally adored nude pink
shade that's on everyone's lips every
celebrity wears it on the red carpet by
the way and I went to the Celine Dion
concert with Margot Joseph's and she was
wearing it too I've been feeling the
shade medium and I've been loving a lip
liner et2 and the pillow-talk lip liner
is everything of the sort it's a little
black dress of makeup it's versatile and
dreamy the perfect pink nude shade to
bring out the most beautiful version of
you the proof is in the numbers America
loves pillow talk in 2019 it was in
number one lipstick in the US and as of
January 16th there are now more pillow
talk shades to love Charlotte is
expanding her iconic pillow talk
collection to include medium and intense
shades of each pillow talk product so
that's a lip liner a lipstick a blusher
and an eye palette the adored iconic
shade is now available to flatter
everyone's natural beauty and can also
be used to dial up your luck for every
mood from day to desk to date and beyond
Charlotte Tilbury shoppable directly
from Charlotte Tilbury calm as well as
their freestanding beauty wonderland at
the Grove in LA sold at most Nordstrom
and Sephora's in North America visit
Charlotte Tilbury calm for your store
finder check it out and thank your
Charlotte Tilbury for being fabulous and
sponsoring this episode
Sion be fabulous it's as simple as that
next story a little update to something
we were just casually discussing
yesterday Delta will be waiting change
fees amid coronavirus
very respectful Delta Airlines will
waive fees for customers needing to
change or cancel flights through March
and April regardless of purchase date
the airline industry became widely
criticized after initially allowing only
new ticket purchases to be waived amid
the corona virus outbreak Delta becomes
the first airline to offer such a broad
fee waiver love to see it love to see it
I hope other airlines follow in its
footsteps American United I'm looking at
you because you know what I've always
been a loyal Delta customer like through
and through and this is not gonna change
my opinion of anything but I hope that
like you know the next time someone goes
to buy a ticket
after this whole they're like respect
and appreciate Delta enough like I hope
that this because of course the company
is gonna lose her a lot of money and
they obviously didn't have to do this so
I hope that it ends up you know
benefiting them and I hope the next time
you go to buy a ticket you remember
maybe the Delta one's a little bit more
expensive but you know they serve fresca
and it's worth it and they were the only
ones to give you a wave to change feet
when coronavirus hit they were the first
ones I'm sure everyone else will follow
suit I don't know it's been a whole day
but they were the first ones and we have
no choice but to respect and really
appreciate like okay I don't have so
much anxiety like we do have a trip to
Vegas land and I have another trip to
Vegas plane but that's the one I got
trip insurance for remember because I
said I just didn't see myself like
because sometimes when I book things so
far in advance I'm like I know who
they're gonna be like yeah so it's just
gonna be morbid but I won't go there
yeah um so I really really appreciate it
now I don't have to make a decision
right now and what's gonna happen we'll
see you know will the invincible tour in
Las Vegas like right be happening like
I'm just you know at my core I'm just a
customer and I just want to be
appreciated for my loyalty and I feel
like you know I'm I'm a delta is great
you know I'm a great rewards and all
their benefits are really great but now
I feel like I'm finally being rewarded
for being such a loyal Delta Delta
customer and I really really appreciate
it so I just want to say thank you too I
want to say his name is Bob the CEO of
Delta you know what I think I could find
it in this I know he's a handsome man
and he's always on that little video
they play before the things take off
yeah I want to say maybe Darren here
I'll get you a Lydia would know that's
why we need them attorney Ed Bastian
that him that sounds really because
she's always on the TV before the flight
takes off love it they have over 90,000
employees I'm telling you as CEOs like
that's where it's at Bob Iger hot no
longer CEO once a CEO
he always a CEO for sure you know it's
hotter than a CEO a CEO I hate [ __ ] like
that like of course up female see I was
amazing but they don't need their own
name they're also just to see ya right
now and to give them their own special
name makes it seem like they're
different when it's not we're all equal
we are okay that's my thing with you
know International Women's Day I
understand but I I look forward to the
day where we don't need International
Women's Day you're sure I understand
that in order for the pendulum to swing
back to equal like it has to be I get it
for me every day truly is International
Women's Day like that's how I live my
life I only consortin with women yeah
for sure
I think also for me honestly actually
these days I think in recent weeks
it's just National Women's Day because
we can't fly internationally because I'm
coronaviruses that's very true yeah
that's very true look current virus just
impacting everything totally you nearly
got screwed with International Women's
Day this year like not only was a
consumed by coronavirus it also landed
on the same day as daylight savings so
we got 23 hours of celebrating ourselves
we spoke about daylight savings at
length yesterday and then the more I
thought about it when I got home like
the more I thought about how [ __ ] up
it is in general but it's also so [ __ ]
up that it happens like on a Saturday
night like the best [ __ ] time of the
week how come it can't happen on Monday
between 12:00 and 1:00 p.m. all of a
sudden oh no I'm sorry that's lunch time
3 & 4 p.m. it's 3 o'clock and then it's
5 o'clock you know like why does it take
why can't it be like out of something
productive or or why not kiddin happen
on Monday between 8 and 10 so it's one
last hour of The Bachelor because it's
Oh totally I thought you meant a.m. I'm
like this one less hours asleep no yeah
no I agree look why can't it just be
like a shorter work day why does it be
like why am i at a bar at one o'clock
and then all of a sudden it's three yeah
I just feel like that should be the next
frontier I know everyone's working
towards a four-day workweek and like
that's great but let's just get let's
work towards like a one less hour
workweek I totally reject of the year
and I did hear from a lot of people
after our show yesterday that the whole
point of daylight saving is for the
farmers
yes that I didn't know I didn't know
that this is for the farmers always they
need an extra hour so I can get you know
an apple on a cool Tuesday morning I
respect that I want to give them that
hour I don't want to take that hour away
from them but I know they take away from
a Saturday night everybody's working for
the weekend are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's so Monday at 3 o'clock I'll see you
there
we the 47 hour weekend this weekend and
I think that's not fair no like the one
one bit of joy we had yeah I can't
minish end and they went and I heard
that Andrew yang who ran for president
but didn't even come close to winning um
and I don't know much about his politics
but his platform included the four-day
workweek
I heard he's thinking about running for
New York mayor and if that's the case
100 percent has my vote yeah you heard
that for me and I can't remember where I
heard it
so I mean see they're totally true or
totally false much like how much a new
show yeah okay fifth and final story a
little business a little fitness news
because Sol cycles at home streaming
bike is finally Oh too late too late it
sounds like you're waiting for it but
too late soul cycle is finally bringing
the unforgettable in studio experience
in studio experience into the comfort of
your own home in a partnership with
Equinox media the two brands are
announcing the official rollout of
varies like from Game of Thrones
um a streaming platform that provides an
immense amount of on-demand fitness
content from cycling to HIIT I believe
that's high interval high-intensity
interval training right at your
fingertips and yes this includes a
long-awaited at-home version of their
famous bikes okay this is interesting
I'm trying to think
aside from coronavirus I don't know when
I actually yesterday was the first day I
did not do musical Monday because of
coronavirus and I think I really this is
the time where I need a bike in my house
yeah I mean also people have bikes in
their house like the peloton they love
it I don't understand it um like you
would think that it's just too late but
this will be successful because people
are obsessed with souls like all they
have a really cult following a lot of
those instructors like throughout the
country have such big fan bases that
like you want to do their class or like
you want to take the same classes when
it's paltrow in New York and that's cool
so it'll be it'll be popular I obviously
don't need it um and I also would never
buy a soul cycle bike because everyone
knows that the soul cycle seat that goes
up your ass is literally like a steel
rod up your ass
so I would be more likely probably to
buy the peloton one I don't know what
their seats are like but I just would
never support a soul cycle seat I would
definitely support this this is the
first time I've actually thought to
myself wait should I get this I never
thought that about peloton but I do like
I am I guess I'm part of like this whole
cycle cult you know that episode of
Kimmy Schmidt where she joins the
cycling class and realizes she's in
another cult
yeah like a truly is that I just can't
really imagine like being so sweaty in
my own house like my house is supposed
to be like my safe I would agree
Haven and I could sweat elsewhere but
like when I'm home I'm chilling with the
Aeron yeah I don't know where I would
put this bike in my house where would
feel comfortable having sweat droplets
just flying off the shelves yeah this is
like a rich person thing where you have
like extra room like just the sweat room
yeah I don't have that yeah I have I
have my eating room my sleeping room and
my sitting room I don't think I would
get one I don't know maybe like I feel
like it's more for you know people with
children like it's like we're so busy
yeah of course no I totally get the need
for it but living in a small apartment
in New York and also being fat I don't
really need it think so but I'm thinking
about it anyways I think that's a great
move for SoulCycle I think that's the
next frontier and I'm glad that they're
staying ahead of it you know and you
wouldn't want to end up like playboy
yeah that's the thing you know you don't
progress and you definitely don't want
to end up like the Detroit secret that's
a cautionary tale for brands everywhere
don't end up like Victoria's Secret like
you can do everything right
business-wise like the real estate the
marketing but if you're not keeping up
with the times what does you do it yeah
it's a sign of the times don't stop your
crying it's a sign of time was that our
final story that was our fifth and final
yes it was so we're gonna recap The
Bachelor which I'm very excited about
because it was actually uh you know lots
of conversations being had about last
night's episode which is the one thing
that The Bachelor usually lacks is
thought-provoking content yes um I have
so many thoughts about like the episode
itself why was it lie you have so many
thoughts about the episode yourself so
do I and I think I'm sorry yeah okay um
so do I and I'm so glad that vistaprint
is here to help as a podcast show so
we're always handing out our business
cards to people we want to work with and
having a totally customized
professional-looking card is an easy way
to make a great first impression when we
hand out our business cards from mr.
print we know we're doing more than
passing along our contact info we're
making a connection we're impressing
potential guests or business partners
with the right business card you make a
statement about yourself that gives you
connect your connections a reason to
choose you and your business over the
competition if you're ready to get
started on your business card it's super
easy plug your information and logo into
hundreds of fresh designs tailored to
your type of company or upload your own
original layout pick the paper stock
style and quantity that's right for you
you can even upgrade to a unique touch
like rounded corners order and receive
your cards with free economy shipping
and as if you needed any more reason to
choose mr. Brent you can feel good
knowing that Vistaprint uses only
carefully selected inks and responds
sourced paper stocks your satisfaction
is 100% guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it right they want you to
be able to own the now in any situation
which is why our listeners will get free
shipping from this to print on all
business cards any style any quantity
just go to vistaprint.com and enter the
promo code toast for free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity but it's a limited time offer
y'all umm now at vistaprint.com promo
code toast sign on own now vistaprint is
everything of the sort if you're getting
your your stuff together and if you like
have ever been in a situation where
someone's like you have a card and you
don't have a card head over to mr.
print.com slash toast
no sorry code test okay let's get into
the bachelor I agree with you the live
element made no sense cuz they didn't
have any interview so we were just going
in and out of the scenes of just people
cheering and clapping and smiling and
frowning how boring to have been in the
audience it was so boring I'm sure they
filmed it all at once but like that is
just a complete waste of no it was live
also something HAP something happened on
YouTube TV last night mister I wasn't
the only one where it just didn't record
the bachelor and I happened to tune in
at 8:15 in the first 15 minutes were
gone
but other people who tuned in like an
hour later it just didn't record so
teeny the drama I wonder why that
happened I don't know so I asked the
snitch what I missed and she said pretty
much nothing except better told his
parents what Madison had said yeah he
gave everyone the down-low um to be
honest like the whole episode was really
filler because Madison Lee is but then
we find out that she comes back but to
me like the most important and the most
cringe-worthy part was Madison actually
also Hannah's both of the meeting of the
families were really awkward because the
way Peter was acting around Hannah and
like was making me wanna vomit like her
in front of your parents like sit up
straight and like stop touching her
vagina like stop I didn't like that and
then the Madi interaction was so
horrible because I mean were you there
like it was horrible it was horrible how
do they like had a fight right before I
thought for sure they weren't gonna meet
his parents yeah I wasn't gonna go in
yeah like we just got to this good place
that's the date goodbye agreed but I
have to like go and charm someone's
parents after that I actually thought
she did a really good job of standing up
for herself when Peter's mom was just
like not letting her talk not being like
a woman who sports other women not at
all okay that conversation between I
thought the way that Maddy spoke to the
dad was so lovely in sir respectful and
I think he was kind of impressed I agree
like it's you go on The Bachelor there's
like token words like I love him he has
my heart but she was just saying
different things like more mature more
self-aware I guess she was aware of the
fact that like it might not be her in
the end because they are so different
and if that is the case she would be
okay with that because she wants what's
best for Peter no one has ever said that
before right and I really respect Maddie
for totally like being self-aware enough
to understand that her and Peter are so
not compatible like they're so different
they live different lives but the one
thing they have in common is that they
love each other like is that enough
that's an interesting conversation and
she's she was conveying that to the dad
and I thought it was going really well
with the dad and I think he was kind of
impressed with her but then the
conversation with the mom just like
threw me for a loop yeah threw me
through a loop also I want to say it's
good to have conversations about what
your life is like outside of the show
and are we compatible but at a certain
point with this show when you get off of
the show and you're a couple like your
life becomes the same inevitably because
you have the same level of fame you're
invited to the same events like maybe
the amount that they drink is different
but they would also see that on the
dates with one another on this show so
even though yes we should be having
conversations about like what are you
doing your spare time how different are
we when it comes to this show you're
thrown into the exact same water style
and it's just a little different but I
do think the conversations about faith
are more important yeah and so when it
got to that point in the conversation
with his mom I thought his mom was uber
disrespectful like I think that first of
all of course every mom I think she
knows what's best for her son and I and
I understand where she's coming from
like wanting to protect her son and
knowing what type of relationships he's
been in before like I don't know if he
can not drink it I don't know if he
could not have sex um but just to make
someone feel so uncomfortable like about
something that's really important to her
and say what you want about Maddie I
think at this point she really could
have wavered in her faith but she's so
many like her principles are so like
important to her and she really stands
by them whether or not you agree with
that you have to respect someone like I
have like I'm so free nearly like I
believe one thing one day and then the
next thing the other day like she really
has such core values that she lets guide
her and she doesn't waver in them and
that is honorable and at the end of the
day she did not give him an ultimatum
no 'has she said this is how I will feel
and she didn't leave when she found out
even though I do think her leaving on
that night date and then coming back was
like kind of [ __ ] up like she loved
his gem thing she came back and now
she's doing that again
and I just I can't like ya know to me I
don't even that's that's the only thing
she's done wrong in my eyes is leave and
come back and now we're gonna see she's
leaving and coming back again and that's
really like throwing Peter like was he
had to propose to Eddie Hannah Anne I
don't know and you know what like the
episode was frustrating for me because
as much as I'm like on Team Madi I still
don't think she's right for Peter and I
still have reservations about her she
gives me really really thirsty vibes
I've just been like seeing her Oliver
tick tock I heard she got at eat like an
agent like she's just freaking me out so
I I can't stress enough that I'm think
what she did is totally justified that
people be like don't go on this show
people forget this is also real life
like you do end up with this person you
do end up hopefully getting married and
it's like this is still an important
part of relationship sex so I don't feel
like she's being unreasonable I don't
think she gave him an ultimatum I
thought the mom was being so
disrespectful not even letting her talk
really like shaming her for having
values and then I just loved Maddy
talking over her like as a queen who
talks over other Queens I was living for
it happening for Maddie yeah I totally
agree and I can't believe that Hannah
Ann was really so able to pull the wool
over the pair of Peters parents eyes and
I understand what they're saying when
something's like so good and right in
front of you like you don't know you
don't need to go chasing down the thing
that you can't have I understand that
message but like there's something about
Hannah
Anne like when she's saying all the
right things and everything so perfect
they've never had even like a quarrel
there's it's called too good to be true
you know it's also it could be as good
as anyone wants it to be he doesn't like
her as much as you like so at a certain
point when he keeps liking girls that
don't like him back like yeah that's on
him and then you do need to choose the
girl that loves you and wants a life
with you but I don't know that that's
necessarily Hannah and I think she just
did a better job at hiding what's
bothering her I mean to be honest
Peter's mom was giving some of the worst
advice like how she could just start
bawling like it was her daughter when
she's known how to and 4 to 15 minutes
and and I got the feeling that this
isn't the type of conversation this
isn't a new conversation in their house
because Peter was like mom stop with the
crying leave their moms crying what do
you do you console her but if she's
always [ __ ] crying you tell her to
stop yeah
so she was just being the mom was being
so unreasonable started control like
literally the dramatics with the sobbing
like she was trying to win an Emmy like
chill she was really bothering me she
was giving Peter such poor advice like
to be honest like if I had a son and
there were two girls and one of the
girls said Peter you know have sex with
whoever you want I'll be here for you
and another one said you know my
feelings will be really hurt if you have
said
someone else who the [ __ ] do you want
your son to end up with the second girl
yeah it was it was just like the worst
advice ever it was though and I think
America is in agreement yeah and she the
dramatics were bothering me so much Oh
after all that speculation that that's
what it was about towards the end of the
episode I started to feel bad for Hannah
and though
oh me too because she's done absolutely
nothing wrong she's not a bad person
she's not a bad person she's actually
seems like a very good person aside from
some of the style choices that she's
making which it's just like I don't
understand but like she knows that it's
not gonna be her I do understand she's
really close no I know she won the
revolve challenge oh yeah I think that
when you are so like great looking and
you have just like a great body and you
never have to like you can buy anything
on any website and it's gonna look good
on you you never have to make decisions
like about how things are gonna look you
know I I could only buy maybe 20% of
clothes on a website because everything
else is a v-neck or it's not my cut or
it's like I understand that about myself
but when you can just wear anything and
everything how are you supposed to know
maybe that's true um she was just me it
was just awful I mean both those dates
in the desert with the Flies in the sand
like oh my god Australia's a beautiful
country go to the beach like what is
with these desert trips I have no idea
and also like Madison took a helicopter
to the date and then went home in a car
how long should she be in the car for 17
hours Oh totally I'm like is he gonna
put her back in the helicopter slow the
car had to try yes um no I do think
Hanna Anne is really sweet I do not
think that her and Peter are magic don't
think she's in love with Peter
whatsoever I think there were a lot of
girls in the house who would have been a
good match for Peter and when it got
down to like the final three none of
them were the girl for him no Kelsey I
think really could have been the
girlfriend I think Kelly could have been
the girlfriend he just went with like
the youngest like snatchy is and that's
just not a good method when you're
looking for like true love yeah I I wish
piers mom had gotten a chance to meet
Victoria he would have she would have
liked her I think they I think they
would have seen each other mom was
bothering me so much and the brother was
like totally roasting Peter just being
and and I we share to see someone's
younger sibling on the show and they
look just like them but like not
literally it's always weird I just I
appreciated everyone like pointing out
the obvious which is that Madison and
Peter are probably not the most
Hannibal and they would have trouble
navigating faith and all that stuff but
to be so rude about it I just thought
was really uncalled for and then how can
Maddie win now she hates the mom and the
mom hates her yeah the one was sobbing
over a girl she met 10 minutes ago and
obviously now the thing that Chris
Harrison tells Peter that we just found
out is that Maddie's back of course so
he's really conflicted but I do think
Maddie cummick leaving and coming back
the annoying is I'm he's unacceptable
and you know what she never looks up
she's always looking down at her fingers
and they're always have their far heads
touching and I was like you love this
man look him in the eyes yeah have
respect like look maybe she can't see
past her eyelashes which are so out of
control they're so out of someone needs
to take her mascara away yeah I kiss I
feel like she has naturally great
eyelashes don't put it on the bottom
just the top and she'll oh no the top
are just too long in spiders the bottom
is our large spider II - yeah it's crazy
they're out of control maybe after
seeing herself on TV she like got
eyelash extensions or something maybe um
no but they all do that for Paradise
they get eyelash extensions and I don't
think that's the movie there because
there's after one day you sleep on your
eyelashes the wrong way you're like a
wonky eyed cockeyed pirate yeah so I
think what's gonna happen is Peter and
because we don't know what happened
because nothing like I don't think he
proposed this to either of them I think
he's been dating Maddie and we'll see
what happens out after the final rose
tonight
yeah I mean whatever he's I'm not on
anyone's team like I don't think either
of them should win I don't think either
of them will have a line long happy life
with Peter um no but I just feel bad
like Madison like getting made fun of
like I just think and I I'm so annoyed
by people like you know what the shows
about like don't go on it for the last
five seasons I think you can pretty much
have it confirmed that this the one
person the bleed only had sex with one
person like you don't normally have sex
with all three people so he could have
just like not done it and not said
anything you know I will say though for
a lot of the last few episodes Maddie
has really been putting Peter like in
the hot seat and asking him like
difficult questions were making him like
just really putting the pressure on him
to like say the right things and I was
glad to see Madison her everything that
she's been saying and doing just not
question but like she needed to really
defend herself and explain and I was
nice for a second that the tables were
turned and also the fact that she was so
like grounded and what
she believed in did not waver like made
me respect her so much but like she had
really been putting it on Peter like
making him you know explained himself
over and over again and I was glad to
see her explain herself let's take a
pause for this Aaron
tonight's episode will be live again so
hopefully they'll be more interesting
things happening in the live segment it
was so silly to like cut back and forth
like to Chris Harrison but Chris
Harrison kept saying he was like giving
it away even Peter doesn't know what's
gonna happen so obviously no one gets
engaged tonight and tonight's just gonna
be another boring episode but at the end
hopefully we'll see some resolution like
has he been with Maddie this whole time
I just thought the end of this season
was gonna like blow some [ __ ] out of the
water like we've never seen before maybe
Hanabi comes back someone's pregnant but
it's really it's Cassie Randolph part
two yeah like checking out yeah then she
comes back with the longest
conversations with about nothing like
that conversation outside of Peters
family's house with just Maddie and
Peter was so long and quiet no one said
anything yeah is love enough so boring
so boring so boring
um we'll be watching tonight in the
snatchers recording tonight so her
episode will be up tomorrow I'm excited
to hear the snatchers thoughts because
she loves Maddie you know I yeah I
haven't been agreeing with anything I'm
with Marta this season so I'll listen
but just you know I don't think I'll
agree with it yeah what you like to see
happen to be honest like I think I'm
very like Peter's been making bad
decisions and he should end up with no
one so he understands that he made bad
decision you know what I would like to
see happen actually they just closed a
lot of books for me Peter ends up with
no one like he doesn't propose because
now he's too conflicted he has spent the
last few months getting reacquainted
with Hannah B and now him in Hannah be
like are in love because like she turned
him down and then he turned her down so
now they're on equal footing together
and they don't have to worry about
Hannah be anymore either you know cuz
you think about her that would be an
interesting end and he did offer her the
Bachelorette but it just wasn't enough
money which means that she is single you
know that they offered her the bachelor
yeah but it also could mean that she's
not single
no but she the reason was because she
was getting it wasn't the paycheck
wasn't big enough maybe that's what they
said perhaps she's with Peter perhaps
that's what I would like to see that way
like it's full circle let's move on
fresh to Claire Crawley who apparently
her season is affected by coronavirus
are they filming they won't be leaving
the u.s. interesting so yeah well recap
tomorrow's episode tonight's episode
tomorrow if you're looking for more
content tomorrow there'll be new
episodes but mood with war and Elizabeth
and Marco Joseph sat down with Brian
Kelly the points guys so that'll be the
bomb Spotify and iTunes Thursday we've
got Olivia's new podcasts maternity
leave launching make sure you're
following a little
Instagram at Olivia ASHRAE make sure you
subscribe to all of these podcasts so
that you never miss when an episode goes
live yeah we love you guys
so much content so little time so much
content that should be our slogan toast
news network so much content so little
time so little time so much to do and
rather spend my days with you
you remember that should be of course
that's um near keen Ashley oh I thought
was S Club 7 thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning to us the
money'll morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I got radio cast
box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcast find us the morning to
us hi maybe subscribe leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are I don't know we'll take
whatever thanks so much have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow hi